No es ningún secreto, Japón tiene problemas.
Unos cuantos problemas. Pero de todos ellos hay
uno que destaca con fuerza: la profunda crisis
demográfica que está experimentando el país.
Japón parece condenado a ir poco a poco
desapareciendo. Es algo de lo que ya os
hablamos hace un tiempo aquí, en VisualPolitik.
Os dejamos el vídeo, en la descripción.
Atentos, por ejemplo, a este titular:
(La población de Japón se reduce en cerca
de 800.000 personas con caídas en todas las
prefecturas por primera vez - The Guardian)
A pesar de que los residentes extranjeros
aumentaron un 10 % en los últimos 14 años,
durante ese mismo periodo la población japonesa ha
caído cada año de forma ininterrumpida. De hecho,
las estimaciones apuntan a que durante
los próximos 40 años Japón perderá casi
40 millones de habitantes. Un millón de
personas por año de media. Por supuesto,
durante este tiempo la población
también será más y más mayor.
Ahora bien, puede que algunos os
estéis preguntando… Pero Enrique,
¿qué diantres tiene todo esto que
ver con el título de este vídeo?
¿Acaso no se supone que íbamos a hablar
de las Fuerzas de Autodefensa japonesas?
Pues veréis, la realidad es que esta crisis
demográfica afecta a todos los terrenos:
el económico, el político
y, sí, también el militar.
Y es que, veréis, según algunos analistas, el
declive demográfico que se va a producir tanto
en Asia como en gran parte del mundo desarrollado
podría conducir a una situación de “paz forzada”.
Es lo que algunos conocen como la “paz
geriátrica”. Según esos analistas,
el envejecimiento de la población generará una
nueva estabilidad geopolítica. Especialmente
teniendo en cuenta que tanto China como Rusia se
enfrentan también a problemas demográficos graves.
(Esta teoría apunta a que, como habrá menos
jóvenes disponibles en la fuerza laboral,
se priorizará que estos se dediquen a trabajar
en la economía productiva para poder sostener el
sistema de bienestar. Pensad que en las
poblaciones muy envejecidas los gastos
sanitarios y de dependencia se disparan,
y eso lo tiene que sostener alguien.
Precisamente por este motivo, esta teoría
sostiene que habrá menos jóvenes disponibles
y también dispuestos a enrolarse en las
fuerzas armadas o hacer el servicio militar.
En consecuencia, según señala esta
teoría, los países serán más reacios
a actuar de forma agresiva, apostando más por
solucionar los problemas de forma diplomática.)
Ahora bien, ¿tiene sentido todo esto? Pues puede
que en algunos lugares esta teoría
se cumpla… Desde luego, lo siento,
pero esta vez no seremos nosotros los que digamos
ni una cosa ni la otra, ni tampoco la contraria.
Ahora bien, en Japón - que es el
país más envejecido del mundo y
algo deben saber de todo esto - no
parece que compren mucho esta idea.
¿Queréis saber por qué? Pues bien,
prestad mucha atención porque en
este tercer vídeo en colaboración con
Harvard International Review os contamos
cómo las Fuerzas de Autodefensa de Japón
esperan reforzarse en una época en la que
habrá muchos menos efectivos disponibles. Os
estamos hablando del tecnoejército de Japón.
Atentos.
T1 (MENOS HOMBRES, MÁS MÁQUINAS)
Fijaos un momento en este gráfico.
Lejos de reducirse, en los últimos años,
especialmente desde 2017, el gasto
militar de Japón respecto al PIB no
ha parado de crecer. En 2020 alcanzó
por primera vez desde finales de los
años 50 el 1% del PIB. Y eso no es
nada comparado con lo que se viene.
El plan de Japón es incrementar su gasto
militar hasta cerca del 2% del PIB,
siguiendo el estándar OTAN, de aquí a 2027.
Esto es mucho, muchísimo dinero. Pensad
que Japón es una economía enorme. Así
que estamos hablando a medio plazo de
entre 40 y 50 mil millones de dólares
más de gasto militar cada año. Las
Fuerzas de Autodefensa de Japón se
convertirán así en las terceras de todo
el mundo en términos de presupuesto.
Hablamos, amigos, de una apuesta militar que
no solo nos demuestra que el envejecimiento
demográfico no necesariamente conducirá
a un menor peso de las fuerzas armadas,
sino que puede ser incluso
todo lo contrario. ¿Por qué?
Pues bien, si miramos a Japón vamos
a encontrar una posible respuesta:
la futura falta de personal en las fuerzas armadas
se quiere sustituir por tecnología y máquinas.
Un cambio que conlleva gastar una cantidad
descomunal de dinero. Para que os hagáis
una idea, Japón quiere inyectar unos
321.000 millones de dólares entre
2023 y 2027 a sus fuerzas armadas. Y
sí, esto es mucho, muchísimo dinero.
(El objetivo nipón, tal y como marca su
última Estrategia de Defensa Nacional,
que es del año 2022, pasa por crear unas fuerzas
armadas más pequeñas en número de efectivos,
pero muchísimo más letales. Es decir, convertir a
un ejército normal en un ejército de unidades de
élite, bien entrenado, muy bien equipado
y con una gran dotación de tecnología.
Y además es algo que se quiere lograr
utilizando sobre todo tecnología
autóctona. Para ello el gobierno japonés
esperará disparar el gasto en I+D militar,
y aprovecharse también del I+D civil como nunca
antes. Supone un cambio total de paradigma.)
Ahora bien, ¿todo esto por qué? ¿Qué
explica que de repente Japón quiera
ponerse las pilas? Pues, aparte de lo
que os comentábamos del reto demográfico,
la explicación la podemos
encontrar sobre todo en China.
Japón se siente cada vez más y más
vulnerable respecto a las crecientes
capacidades militares de China y
el discurso cada vez más hostil con
occidente de los gerifaltes de Pekín. No solo
en términos militares sino también políticos.
De hecho, llama mucho la atención que el
país del sol naciente, a pesar de ser la
tercera economía mundial, parece tener poca
influencia internacional. Pensadlo bien,
¿Alguna vez tenéis en cuenta la opinión de Tokio
en los grandes debates internacionales? Pues eso.
Si quitásemos su pertenencia al
G7 hablaríamos de un país que la
verdad pinta muy poco en la esfera política
internacional. Países como Alemania o Canadá,
teniendo economías más pequeñas, tienen mucho
más peso internacional. Incluso Corea del Sur,
que se ha convertido en un importante
proveedor en el sector de la defensa o
de la energía civil, ya rivaliza
con el peso político que Japón.
Y eso, queridos amigos, es
algo que ahora el gobierno
japonés también quiere cambiar.
Más recientemente, con su entrada
en alianzas militares como el Quad, se está
revirtiendo esta situación. Pero hace falta
más. Y aquí contar con unas fuerzas armadas
realmente capaces puede resultar fundamental…
Tanto para la influencia internacional
como para la propia seguridad nacional.
Como ya os hemos comentado en varias ocasiones,
Pekín está llevando a cabo un proceso
de modernización militar muy acelerado
en los últimos años. Las fuerzas armadas
chinas cada vez están mejor equipadas.
(Algunos analistas militares ponen
incluso fecha para que China logre
estar preparada para invadir Taiwán
si así lo quisiera: el año 2027.
Y, claro, dada la experiencia con la invasión
rusa de Ucrania, ahora las amenazas militares de
gigantes contra países más pequeños y débiles
se ha empezado a tomar mucho más en serio.
En el caso de Taiwán, una hipotética
invasión china tendría graves implicaciones
para Japón. No solo dejaría a sus islas
sudoccidentales mucho más expuestas a Pekín,
sino que además los efectos sobre la economía
japonesa podrían llegar a ser devastadores.
Taiwán produce buena parte de los semiconductores
y de la tecnología más avanzada que demanda la
industria japonesa. Y hay muchas empresas
niponas que directamente fabrican allí.
Si se cortase ese suministro,
el golpe podría ser letal. Y,
por supuesto, tampoco podemos olvidarnos
de Corea del Norte, que ya ha demostrado
ser capaz de atacar cualquier parte de
Japón con misiles con capacidad nuclear.)
Pero, esperad un momento porque si pensáis que
en este vídeo simplemente os íbamos a contar que
Japón quiere comprar armas más modernas, lo
cierto es que eso es tan solo el principio.
El plan de Japón para conseguir
unas fuerzas armadas totalmente
distintas a como las conocemos
a día de hoy va mucho más allá.
Por ejemplo, recientemente el Ministerio de
Defensa nipón publicó las Directrices de Defensa
Tecnológica de 2023. Hablamos de un documento que
cambia radicalmente la forma en la que las fuerzas
armadas se relacionan con la economía privada, con
las universidades y hasta con el propio gobierno.
Lo que os vamos a contar a continuación
seguro que sorprende a más de uno.
Queridos amigos, amigas, así es
como Japón quiere convertirse en
uno de los países más innovadores del
mundo en materia de defensa. Atentos.
T2 (UNA FUERZA ‘BETA’)
Vale, creo que no os voy a descubrir la pólvora
si os digo que las fuerzas armadas japonesas
arrastran problemas de capacidades impo rtantes
tras años y años, décadas de infrafinanciación.
Y es que, veréis, tras la caída del Imperio
japonés y el lanzamiento de las bombas atómicas
por parte de Estados Unidos para forzar su
capitulación en la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
la sociedad japonesa quedó
completamente traumatizada.
El país, que durante el siglo pasado fue
un régimen militarista e imperialista que
causó un enorme reguero de destrucción y de muerte
por media Asia, ahora es uno de los
más pacifistas de todo el planeta.
De hecho, la inmensa mayoría de los japoneses,
estaban en contra de aumentar el gasto en defensa.
A principios de la década de 2010, apenas
una cuarta parte de los japoneses se
mostraba favorable a incrementar
el gasto en defensa. Sin embargo,
a día de hoy, esa cifra ha subido ya
a más del 60 %. [Del sushi al misil
guiado, digamos, los gustos de los japoneses
han cambiado radicalmente en apenas 10 años.]
Pues bien, la cuestión ahora es que para
materializar el aumento del presupuesto
en forma de resultados, el
gobierno de Fumio Kishida,
que por cierto desciende de una familia
de Hiroshima, la ciudad más pacifista
y antimilitarista del país, ha trazado
una vía muy peculiar: el tecnoejército.
Y es que, veréis, hasta ahora el ejército
japonés se había centrado en desarrollar
armamento propio de tipo convencional. Hablamos
de tanques, barcos y aviones de combate.
Sin embargo, paralelamente, la amenaza
más directa de Japón, que es China,
ha estado trabajando en armas no convencionales
y altamente tecnológicas, como armas de energía
dirigida con láser, armas electromagnéticas,
cañones de riel o drones de todo tipo.
(La marina china está probando el cañón
helicoidal más potente jamás construido
Las armas de bobina, también conocidas como
aceleradores magnéticos, podrían provocar cambios
enormes en la forma en que se libran las guerras,
allanando el camino para ataques más devastadores
contra objetivos enemigos - Business Standard)
(China reivindica el desarrollo de un cañón
de riel electromagnético frente a sus
rivales EE.UU. y Japón - The Defense Post)
Sobre algunas de estas superarmas
ya os hablamos en un pasado vídeo
que os dejamos aquí abajo en la descripción.
El caso es que todo esto, sumado a la cada
vez mayor agresividad en la retórica del
régimen chino, ha hecho que los japoneses se den
cuenta de que es muy, pero que muy posible que
de seguir las cosas como están pronto no podrían
hacer frente a una agresión por parte de Pekín.
Y por supuesto tampoco serían capaces de
defender sus intereses en la región… Por ejemplo,
no podrían hacer absolutamente respecto a
Taiwán. Su capacidad de disuasión sería nula.
Por eso la pregunta, la gran
pregunta que podemos hacerlo es,
¿cuál es la solución que ha propuesto
Tokio? Pues básicamente aprovechar una de
sus grandes fortalezas como país y disparar
la investigación y el desarrollo de nuevos
tipos de armamento. Pero no de la forma en
la que se ha estado haciendo hasta ahora.
(Hasta ahora las Fuerzas de Autodefensa
comunicaban al Ministerio de Defensa cuáles
eran las capacidades que necesitaban. Después,
el Ministerio estudiaba qué armamento tendría
preferencia y encargaba a contratistas
privados su desarrollo y fabricación.
Luego, durante años, la industria de
defensa iba construyendo prototipos
que probaban y probaban hasta la
saciedad y los iban mejorando hasta
conseguir el modelo final. Después,
ese modelo final tenía que pasar por
una certificación del Ministerio de
Defensa antes de entrar en servicio.)
El caso es este proceso podía
durar entre 10 e incluso 20
años hasta que ese armamento entraba en
funcionamiento. Durante todo ese tiempo,
además, iban apareciendo muchas tecnologías que
simplemente se quedaban fuera del producto final.
Un ejemplo lo tenemos en el tanque Tipo 90.
Un armamento que las Fuerzas de Autodefensa
tardaron 13 años en desplegar desde que se
solicitó hasta que se completó el diseño final.
Es decir, el resultado con este modelo de
producción solía ser un producto desfasado.
O al menos uno que ya no estaba a la
vanguardia de la industria militar.
Este es modelo de diseño y desarrollo que
se conoce como “modelo en cascada”. Cada
paso del proceso va uno tras otro, y no empieza
el siguiente hasta que se completa el anterior.
Pues bien, esto es justo con lo que el
Ministerio de Defensa de Japón quiere
acabar de raiz. Acabar de una vez por todas con
el modelo en cascada. Ahora bien, ¿cómo hacerlo?
Pues de una forma que igual a muchos os
llama la atención a algunos y a otros,
incluso, os puede llegar a escandalizar:
hablamos de promover la fusión de la I+D
militar y la I+D civil. O al menos eso
es lo que se plantea en la práctica.
Y ya sé lo que puede que muchos estéis pensando…
¿Pero acaso esto no es algo
parecido a lo que hace China?
Pues… En esencia sí, pero con matices. Como
siempre, el diablo está en los detalles.
(En un horizonte de 10 o más años vista,
Japón quiere que las empresas privadas con
componente de I+D así como las universidades
se unan a las instituciones y agencias públicas
de investigación, tanto civiles como militares,
y al propio Ministerio de Defensa
para trabajar codo con codo.
Lo que se busca es que las tecnologías civiles
más avanzadas, como los mejores drones,
la inteligencia artificial o numerosos
software de análisis masivo de datos,
se puedan fusionar e integrar rapidamente
para crear armas remotas e incluso autónomas.
La idea es conseguir la superioridad tecnológica
y al mismo tiempo reducir a la mínima expresión la
cantidad de hombres necesarios para realizar
operaciones militares. O en otras palabras,
lanzar más máquinas al campo de batalla
en caso de necesitarlo, y menos personas.)
(Japón lanza una agencia de
investigación de tecnología
de defensa y avanza un proyecto de
cañón de riel - IPDefense Forum)
Todo esto que os acabamos de contar tendría como
mínimo un par de ventajas
y un par de inconvenientes.
La primera ventaja es que, en un escenario
de envejecimiento y caída de la población,
Japón podría mantener e incluso
mejorar sus capacidades de defensa,
lo cual no se creía posible bajo
la teoría de la “paz geriátrica”.
La segunda ventaja es que, en caso de conflicto,
se arriesgarían muchas menos vidas japonesas.
Pero también tiene algunas
desventajas. La primera,
por su puesto, es su coste. Desarrollar un
ejército con estas capacidades resulta carísimo,
y se comerá buena parte de esos 321.000
millones de dólares de gasto militar hasta 2027.
Y luego la segunda desventaja que puede tener
es la insensibilización y deshumanización de
la guerra. Esto al final se podría traducir
en más víctimas civiles en caso de conflicto
y guerras más cruentas. Es decir, un
resultado muy distinto al esperado.
Ahora bien, ¿es todo esto realista?
Seguro que muchos estáis pensando…
Madre mía… vaya película se han
montado los japoneses. ¿Verdad?
Pues lo cierto es que, a falta, eso sí, de que
haya planes más concretos, las directrices parecen
muy serias, y las fuerzas armadas de Japón irán
por ese camino durante esta y la próxima década.
(De hecho, uno de los grandes pilares
de esta nueva estrategia es que el
modelo en cascada de desarrollo de
armas sea desterrado para siempre.
Según este nuevo enfoque, las armas desarrolladas
conjuntamente por la industria de la defensa y el
sector civil entrarían en funcionamiento en
las Fuerzas de Autodefensa en fase prototipo.
En cuanto tuvieran funcionalidades reales
de combate empezarían a ser utilizadas.)
Luego serían los propios reportes por
parte de las fuerzas armadas las que
harían mejorar esos prototipos a lo
largo de los años hasta llegar a un
producto final totalmente funcional.
Es un sistema de desarrollo constante.
Vamos, unas fuerzas armadas
en fase beta constante.
Ahora bien, ¿por qué se quiere hacer esto? ¿Por
qué tantas prisas? Pues básicamente
por lo que os hemos comentado antes.
Los japoneses creen que China les está comiendo
el terreno en materia de tecnología militar,
y tienen que apretar, cueste lo que cueste para
mantener su capacidad de disuasión y combate.
Además, en el nuevo plan también está
que todo el nuevo armamento desarrollado
por Japón tenga estándares OTAN, para
así mejorar la interoperabilidad con
sus aliados y facilitar la exportación
del nuevo armamento que se desarrolle.
Ahora bien, llegados a este punto,
¿queréis ejemplos concretos de lo que Japón
tiene entre manos bajo este nuevo esquema?
(Pues veréis, al margen de
mejorar el cañón de riel,
que ya se ha probado incluso sobre un
barco, Japón busca desarrollar una serie
de nuevas armas no convencionales,
no tripuladas o incluso autónomas.
Armas ultraconectadas a la redes como
la 5G que se puedan usar desde miles de
kilómetros de distancia aprovechando la
bajísima latencia de estas nuevas redes.
Pero hay más. Una de las cosas que primero
quieren poner en funcionamiento es un sistema
de microondas de alta potencia. Hablamos
de un arma de energía dirigida para,
en el caso de japón, hacer frente
a ataques de saturación con drones.
También se busca priorizar el uso de tipos
no convencionales de energía para hacer
funcionar el armamento, y la creación de nuevos
materiales, en teoría mucho más perfectos.)
De hecho, en las directrices recién
publicadas se hace referencia al
desarrollo de un nuevo material
que no solo sea más resistente,
sino que tenga una microestructura
perfecta capaz incluso de regenerarse.
Pero las ideas de Japón para el futuro no
solo se quedan en tecnologías aplicables al
armamento ofensivo. También buscan utilizar armas
mucho menos comunes de las que podáis imaginar.
¿Un ejemplo? Pues Japón quiere crear verdaderos
sistemas de propagación de información falsa. Sí,
de fake news de toda la vida…
Pero llevados a otra división.
Me explico. A través de la inteligencia
artificial, el metaverso, y de tecnologías
muy avanzadas de deep fake o incluso a través
de la proyección de hologramas estereoscópicos,
Japón quiere engañar al enemigo tanto
dentro como fuera del campo de batalla.
¿Cómo? Pues dispersando esa información para hacer
creer cosas que no son y ganar
ventaja en caso de conflicto.
Incluso hablan de proyectar objetos como si
fueran reales. Hablaríamos de tecnologías que,
en mayor o menor medida, ya se empiezan a usar
en la esfera civil, pero que el ejército de Japón
quiere adoptar, adaptar y mejorar hasta su máxima
expresión para convertirlas en armas letales.
Puede que para muchos todo esto que os estamos
contando os resulte una locura.
Y no creáis que no os entiendo.
Pero os digo una cosa: todo lo que os
estamos contando aparece en las nuevas
Directrices de Defensa Tecnológica. Así que
sí, esto es lo que Japón tiene entre manos.
La duda, la gran duda que todos seguramente
tengamos es… ¿Lo conseguirán? ¿Se convertirán
las fuerzas armadas de Japón en unas fuerzas
futuristas, ultraconectadas y super-mecanizadas?
Pues bien, solo el tiempo dirá. Y
seguro que aquí en VisualPolitik
os hablaremos de ello. Por el
momento podéis dejar vuestras
opiniones sobre todo esto que os hemos
contado aquí abajo, en los comentarios.
Espero que esté nuevo entre VisualPolitik
y Harvard International Review os haya
resultado tan interesante
como a nosotros. Si es así,
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros al
canal si es que aún no lo habéis hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.